today I'm at the University of Sydney  talking to rod cross who's done physics  for many many decades perfectly correct  I was a student here in 1960 Wow so he  certainly knows a lot about physics and  today we're doing an experiment  involving a slinky can you tell me about  it  well I have here a slinky in my hand I'm  going to hold the slinky by the top end  let the bottom and go so the slinky  stretches and it angrily and I'm going  to ask the question what happens when I  let go at the top end will the bottom  end fall first will the top end fall  first well both ends fall together or  will the center of the slinky stay at  rest and the top end and the bottom end  approach each other and I collapse in  the middle make your prediction and then  I'll drop it ready set go  [Laughter]